foreign
do the same one again
and again nope I do it again
okay
[Music]
you're gonna do it again and I don't you
don't need to change anything about you
you just do you
I want you to pay attention to her left
elbow plot it in space and you go
did you do you see how it's you're gonna
keep doing that when you tell me what's
happening to that left elbow as you plot
it in space
describe what's happening who's slightly
there and then stays still here say
speak up
you move slightly at the beginning and
then stays still through the rest of the
time all right let's find out stop
I'm gonna plot it in space right there
you do the throw looks like it went
towards the east okay so you weren't
accurate so you're gonna do it again
watch the elbow
do you see okay
we'll have you you guys go
dead nugget Taylor
let's again moving away from me and
you're gonna plot his elbow in space
nope you're always gonna go North you're
always going to throw North you're
plotting his elbow
[Music]
Aaron what what do you what do you
notice as you plot it in space
anything what do you notice
what
is it staying still or is it moving in
space
it's moving pay attention it's moving
Eastward again watch watch prior to the
throat you see
it's going Eastward again okay uh we'll
come back we'll do the other parent and
you're gonna do the same thing you don't
have to change anything
and uh we're gonna now plot for the hand
in Space the wrist scrub
what do you notice
right pay attention what the same
direction it's going in the same
direction so if we plot look at the
distance the wrist is currently from her
torso
do you understand now watch as he throws
it got closer to her torso do you see
that and that's a product of that elbow
hinging
that's why the risk gets closer
do you understand okay so we're gonna
come and we'll
switch to other team watch that
and again you see how the Hat the wrist
gets closer
you see which is telling you that elbow
is hinging
got it
okay
so and you don't have to worry push push
push okay I don't want to stay here or
do
any kind of segmentation
to get things together
you see the segmentation
right right at contact
you have
let me see this isn't getting closer
this is stay there you can use me for
balance sheet relaxed this is not
hinging
you see that
uh so write at contact
everything stays the same so even this
little shoulder you think don't no no
shoulder hinge
so you want to do the movement then
okay
same thing I'm going to come up
but I'm not going to let these hinges
work
up
she she's going she's trying to go in
but I'm not going to let her
if we pay attention to the uks
the UK is disconnect all the time all
the time okay
um
so if you pay attention to when so she
pushes she's now not disconnected but
when does she when does she want that
right there
let's say that right here is where
she'll take her Center out of the
technique and so the internal
uh energetic manipulation she's trying
to desegment it she's trying to
disconnect it you see and then the
hinges will become viable again so this
kind of Luca
gives you a great opportunity
to you see there it is again
so
once once I have her here I have her
Center so you can see if you can move
her in any anywhere you want
but once she goes off balance she's now
changing the angle and disconnecting the
center
what you have to do as your Advanced is
not go back to a hinge she changed the
vector so you just keep the energy
instead
got it so I don't want to do the keyhole
at the cost of bringing her joints back
in
I just I have the energy the energy is
what I use
every time she disconnects
I keep that lock on her joints so just
hear that you see how she goes back okay
what she's hoping those to do push this
push okay but she goes back go back and
same thing I can't keep going where she
disconnected
she goes back and I keep
the same thing do you feel how do you
see and the joints don't hinge
got it okay Chris
so this I don't want that
see
it's just the feeling of
when does it happen
right when he's about to fall
okay
so maybe I take the keyhole up to that
part
he starts to pull out and hinge do you
see now to continue on this now here's
where you can push down on that hand you
see
he'll he he's given back leverage to
himself which is what a resistant person
will do
they will do that and that's why they
this kind of uke is not the best for you
not good development but for my
knowledge of development it'll help me
train so when I feel that you see how I
felt it goes yeah
you see how I put it back on okay
so we'll do that one again just so I can
talk it through as I feel him pull that
do you see rather than push here and
give him the mechanical advantage there
right I brought this this way
this is going this way see and what you
notice is that the hinge stops working
every time
there's that little hinge
there it is again
there's that hinge
you see
trying to take energy off it can go down
if you understand so pay attention to
this
segmentation
and as you can
because you're training
from the inside of the young side
throwing architecture throwing
architecture
you want to make yourself throwable and
save the counters for geoism
okay
so
as I do the prescribe do you see
I have
established by Prescription Center to
Center relationship you feel that okay
so if the camera doesn't feel what you
feel but you see if I continue to do it
you see how I did the same thing
I have her joints not working so
okay so when you I establish that Center
and you start to go and then I came off
hi TC
I keep the same Center
okay
now here's the interesting part you
might be be very interested in not
training in a drill where my response is
prescribed you might go that's a bunch
of I would rather learn how to
do something when people counter okay
again save that for GI Wasa but if I
maintain Center
you're going to see
you're never going to throw me
because you segment okay so I've become
a much harder okay
making you fail more not succeed more
than the UK who disengages okay so I'll
do the disengagement you get and do you
go ahead and tell me
I want you to be able to describe what
you're feeling
the weight is getting taken off right as
you're going off balance a little bit
Topsy turdy not really but yes okay so
I'll keep that description in mind and
now I I get into your Center
so every little manipulation
starts where where it leaked out before
as UK
now
takes away from your throwing
uh Force because it's leaking out there
too
see so as you move from here where I
established Center to Center As you move
from here
go ahead and move
okay
you're gonna do the technique
okay I'm just feeling all of that
leakage
there it is again
so imagine you're a you're a noggin
and Sensei says you get four tries
and
then your partner gets four try so we
bowed in and we go
one
two
three
oh my turn
foreign
okay so again change your mindset
um
don't prioritize
throwing them it's how you throw them
and equally it's how you fulfill your
role as you can okay do you understand
that so
I don't
it's not very high
chill okay
lay down on your shoulder
no
you don't need that elbow right
just put your shoulder on the ground
there you go
and did you see how you gives you real
life okay just go
that's it
now this is very mushy
I'm gonna push
good now lower your shoulder without
that getting mushy
yes can you see how different that
looked do it again
yes
good do you see her body is different
can you see it or it's not visible you
look like you're doubting it's visible
can you see it okay can you feel it okay
do your segmented shoulder
you're going to put your shoulder down
that's that's a fear response hey this
is too high for your mind
so you go a little at a time now now
I'll now I'll risk it okay and now be
segmented
different body okay
so what you want to do is not be afraid
because fear segments the body
a locked
locked
no I
again you you have to use your mind
I can't be pushing on this all the time
hey you use the mind
nope
do you see hey
pressurize
then it happens right at the fear
response of falling okay
so if you if that's the case
then doing the prescribed in chemical
which is the role of rookette not the
Folly okay
I get to reconcile fear I'm brought to
the fear crisis the fork in the road
which will you do will you go
unconscious
can you see will you segment and then
you go unconscious or will you maintain
awareness in the face of that
gravitation that egocentrism
it's a choice okay and as you as you can
make yourself
be that do that you get eight reps per
every four not four reps okay
pay attention to those joints both from
UK
and if they do do it from not yet
get them back out of play okay good
foreign
to the functioning they're articulating
the articulation in her joints I have
the wrist elbow and the shoulder
what do you notice
there seems to be a little
band or going back and on some of the
rubs anyone else notice anything
there's energy leakage yes there's
energy leakage which which who could who
could Define
what is not being impacted as a result
of that energy leakage the center the
center is not being affected so the
center is being sequentially externally
affected so as you work through each
joint
then eventually you're pulling on the
center do you understand that okay so
the same thing is here
okay so uh when I'm here you see I'm in
the center it's in your Center that's
why when you try to disconnect what you
feel this hand is doing
where is it
yeah do you see okay
as opposed to you go ahead and
disconnect and I disconnect too okay as
you get and then inversely it's the same
thing here right so as you as I go into
your joints because you disconnect it go
ahead and do your thing do you see it
like that now the joints become
functional again but if I if you get to
that point and you disconnect you see
and I'm still in the
the center but from a different vector
and you have to be able to do it on the
fly in the joints stop functioning every
time the joints function
you're going to lose connection to the
center okay
so if you if you watch her Center and
we've just plot it in space is it moving
is it is it is it moving through the
sagittal plane that's
on the map
or is it rotating
are the distal ends of her body rotating
around her Center okay such that it's
because the center is spinning
okay like a imagine a
ball bearing when I'm spinning it okay
or I'm actually doing some combination
of both and they're spiraling through
space like the corkscrew roller coaster
so if we plot her body in space do you
see uh and I do this technique here I'm
just going around each joint
you see that
until it goes down
again what does that UK usually do
reconciles the absence of a mechanical
advantage of absence of a mechanical
advantage okay so she'll go down
[Music]
but because I have my Center
do you see
go ahead
and if I add my intern go ahead if I had
my internal skills to it
she's not gonna get me
okay
what I want to do is establish kazushi
so that her ability to resist is less
doable because you're mechanically being
disorganized okay so as opposed to
you pushing
and I get out of the way
she's Perfect Balance do you see
so I'm not getting out of the way you're
going to have to travel as we move
camera as I get out of the way there's
perfect balance until
she reconciles the energy if she was
stronger or until each joint starts
working up its way to the factory Center
okay
so
instead I'm going to immediately the
same same feeling that I have there I do
on a yield
okay I don't just get out of the way and
disconnect the grip from her Center
same same feeling there I keep that
feeling
so let's look as I take get out of her
Center watch her steps watch your steps
what'd she do last night
she took that little stutter right so
same feeling there that on there I keep
boom
you see okay now wait go stay there
where you are
watch me go off
do you see I'm off stand back up
okay go back where you were okay and
same thing do you feel it it's in am I
in the lock
no I'm not here's the law
get back up
go back where you are you felt something
though right but it's not the lock
got it do you think
try to stand up oh a little harder Right
add the movement shh
so from here I have it from here I had
it in your Center have it
same projection right going around
come back
here
look at her joints
Flex them in and out
you see usable boom
you feel the difference not not usable
so here I don't go around this I keep
this relationship
that same relationship
what do you do as a result of that
relationship pay attention
what'd you do nope feel that pressure
that you call the lock
tell me if it goes off
by what you do
yeah it did
do you feel that friction
it's off your joints are back do you see
that
you got to be able to feel that okay do
you see how it's on look I'll show you
you see now I can move her come back
as you feel that
reconcile the the pressure you feel
it's off again there stay there go back
reconcile it
take the pain off is what that means
take the pain off you see it's off safe
stay stay there come around
watch your joints
do you see go back
we're gonna go really slow as you take
me to reconcile the energy
what am I doing
keeping it on
you see
that's another attempt to take it off
go around again you'll see It'll be off
you see it's off again go back
so as each reconcile that she does I
keep the joint non-functioning
as I go into
the technique it stays on
on
again she's trying to take it off the
faster you move the faster I have to
move okay I'm keeping it on
do you see that
on
okay now I don't want to
see
I don't want to go here
that's not where it's on
okay I have to go into your Center
in your Center you feel that difference
natural my projection is
okay
try again
so now you're not in Coco Dosa you're in
kihon Masa
the concepts of principles are the same
but the prescriptions are not the same
okay so
as I go into his Center just like hope
you Dosa do you feel it there it is he's
going to reconcile that energy and get
back into my Center
okay and I'll show you he because he can
do a projection through my Center
you get it okay
this is where the Nico starts in the guy
being in my center and now like you
weren't supposed to do in cookie Dosa I
attempt to regain my Center you see that
so he he has it
and I'm gonna
get it back
do you see that
but before I segment
he keeps that same connection as I am
attempting to do that okay do you see so
again project me
you see that so I'm taking you Kimmy
he's keeping that same feeling he'll
move wherever he needs to move to at any
point be able to project me again
Center I keep reconciling it to free my
Center
okay now we're down at the bottom and
I'll show you I have my Center which
should mean I can do what to him
project
there
but I am okay
so I receive his projection again he's
not trying to
just deal with my joints he's got that
same feeling
and now he projects my Center
that is
but that's also a lion okay so he's not
just attacking my joints and I go ah
there's little counters that I'm doing
now to this point if I over counter
then he would because in his task just
keep connection that much faster
do you get it that's what you were doing
so you you over countered too quickly
and you weren't ready for the
continuation why is it a problem
let's say
I start to fall
and I'm going that way
don't don't change this okay
don't change leave it in space where it
is um I'm gonna fall this way
looks like it works
but I'm gonna do that slow and you're
gonna see that he's gonna have to go
over the top to keep the center
and at this point as I start to fall I'm
now going against
the lock as I put him back into there
you see that so and now your knockout
has a choice don't break my wrist right
you get it
or break our wrist okay
so don't fall
instead just reconcile and again you can
see
just reconcile
and he'll continue
okay
I don't why are you not switching
okay so again you're in his joint if we
if we you're in her joint too so if we
watch how much of the move has started
there's not he's just standing there do
you see this is where a resistant
opponent punches you in the face okay so
you would go no no nothing in the center
nothing now here says the joints worked
their way up until they affected his
posture
as as a sense of something different
he'll he's in a crowd right and because
you can project at any point which means
I'm anti-centered right I'm not going to
be in his arm not in his arm okay the
second contact becomes sick so I'm gonna
I'm gonna move through the architectural
pattern of Nico okay and I'll stop at
various increments and Inspire geometry
and you'll see that I can always project
okay so I'm going to start to move
they've been that first floor and again
keep moving
and again there's there it is right
there okay
uh I'm gonna go in under the technique
here we are
same thing
boom in the center I'm cutting through
the technique same thing in the center
same thing in the center and you have to
move so you can don't live okay we're
getting into the technique same thing
projects in the center form
in the center
always in the center
get to the bottom
same thing
project even even without the obvious
movement of my hands that way is still
in his Center
okay and you can at all times
reverse it
[Music]
okay which you cannot do when you're
only in the joints okay